You know, obviously this is my country, this is my home.
And the idea that a big let's face it,
a big chunk of this country does not see me as American.
It does not accept me as American, even though I know it's not,
the problem is not with me. The problem is with them.
It's still a little heartbreaking to me and it's still, it still gets to me,
you know, uh, the fact that what is it,
44% of the country probably wouldn't see me as,
as belonging here.
I feel like you might be an exception, my friend,
where if they've seen you in something that all of a sudden you become familiar
to them in a way that, um,
that that might hopefully, uh, engender, uh, you know,
some positivity. I feel like you'd get that.
If you went to a lot of places and when you were performing your comedy,
I feel like you might know this country in a way that a lot of people don't
because comedians head to small towns and medium-sized cities
and work like a club where, like you said, like, you know,
a few dozen drunk people show off that they're there.
And you're there with a bunch of other comics that you ended up staying
overnight in places that a lot of Americans will never see and never visit.
Did you have that experience as a comedian or were you more exclusively in
Chicago? In New York?
Um, I certainly had that experience. Not as much.
I couldn't do it in Chicago because I couldn't make money.
So I would go sometimes do the shows just to do them,
but certainly in New York I have done tours of tiny, tiny towns. And,
you know, I grew up in a really big city. I grew up in Karachi,
which is like 20 million people. I've I lived in Chicago. I lived in,
lived in New York.
So I was always very like metropolitan going to these small towns was
really very eye-opening because I'll be honest, you know, before I went to them,
I was a little bit, I thought, Oh, I, I, I don't see the appeal.
Like if I lived there, I would move out. But then going there,
you do a show in a tiny town. I did this show thinking of this specific one.
I did a show in a tiny town in Ohio. Then afterwards,
everybody went to a bar and all the people from the show went to the bar and I
was kind of hanging out and talking to these people who sort of grown up there.
And some of them had been like best friends with each other since the second
grade, you know? Um, and I thought that that was really beautiful.
And even though a lot of these people may not agree with me politically now,
I really,
I realized that as trite as this sounds,
we all truly have a lot more in common than we don't.
I know sometimes it's, that gets obscured by, by, um,
by just the conversation and, and sort of the screaming at each other. But, uh,
I, it made me feel ultimately optimistic about,
about where we're headed in this grand experiment.
The only thing comedians, uh,
could be the great unifying of our
society in part,
because of those experiences that so many of you had.
A lot of pressure to put on a bunch of drugs and drug addicts, dude.
Just in, uh, um, well, w one place that feels very, very uplifting.
And I I'd urge you to try and get there though.
I guess it'd be far field for you. Uh, you know, then you're, you know,
you're probably not going to, you know, break isolation. Um,
but Dave Chappelle has, uh,
as a cornfield near his house and he's been doing live comedy shows there with,
uh, comedians who just come and go, essentially, I think they,
their nickname for it was Chappelle summer camp. So yeah,
it actually takes some of the ingredients you're describing where it's a very
small town, but people are discovering,
it's essentially like a field of dreams of comedy.
The whole thing blows your mind.
Like you go there and because it's a corn field,
everyone's spread out and it's very socially distanced. You're just like,
what am I seeing?
I'm seeing like some of the best comedians in the world in this
cornfield. Uh, and it felt quintessentially American in part,
because of the backdrop. It's like just fields of corn in the summer.
It was a gazebo anyway. So, um, but,
but the comedians I talked to because they interact with people in the same way
you do, it's like, look, we all have a lot in common.
We all want the same things. Uh,
and there are these political discussions that are trying to pit us against each
other in a way that I don't think would apply if we were just sitting across the
kitchen table from each other, or if we were in the same bar at the same night,
like then you would just end up bonding over your common humanity, uh,
instead of, you know,
typing some nasty comment in Twitter or Facebook or,
or what have you. Um, so I'm,
I'm serious that I feel like, uh,
comedians are having a different conversation with Americans, uh,
than politicians, for sure. Like a better conversation in, in many respects.
I think that's right. I think that's right. Um, what you said about, you know,
I w one of my best friends in the world is India and people always like a
Pakistani and Indian, and it's like, yeah,
those lines don't exist when you're like sitting next to someone or
eating with them. You know, I always find like, if you look at the big SIG,
there's a lot of eating scenes that happen whenever people, uh,
whenever walls come down and people connect. And I really feel like, you know,
if, if, if the world could,
if I could bring some of these people in and feed them Pakistani food,
I don't think they could think of that place in the way that they think of it
right now. Cause cause our foods do.
Yes,
well said Kumail's effort will be like Pakistani restaurants across the
country. Letting people know that this place is too delicious to dislike.
Right. I mean, that is what we are.
We're too delicious to dislike that that should be on our flag. That, that,
I mean, that's a.
Pretty good tagline, uh, comedians and chaps bringing the world together.
I don't, I don't mind it. Uh,
so when you talk about the politics of this moment, so you've got a green card,
um, are you a citizen now or are you still trafficking? And I am. Oh,
so you have the freaking full rights and privileges. You took the test.
Was the test as hard as they say.
No, the test was pretty easy. Um, in fact why I,
I don't know how much I get sick, cause I don't.
Cause I read some things where they were like, Oh,
we can start revoking citizenships and all this stuff.
Oh, you're in for good. Don't worry about it. You can spill the beans.
Nothing's going to happen. It's irreversible.
I went in and I sat with this guy and I was really nervous and he was an Asian,
he was an Asian guy. Very nice. And uh, right from the beginning, he was like,
he asked me a couple of questions and then he saw I was nervous and he was like,
don't be nervous. You're going to pass. Don't worry about this.
And I just thought it was really, really sweet. Like he didn't have to do that.
He didn't have to put me at these, you know,
he didn't have to make me feel better.
The person who interviewed us for the green card certainly didn't do that.
She was trying to get us. She was trying to get us to contradict ourselves and,
and you know, she was like, she was certainly like aggressive. Uh,
but this guy was super nice. So th the, the test wasn't, it was not that hard.
No. So yeah, I'm here for good kind of get rid of me.
Yeah, look, it is full rights and privileges. So, so, and you know,
you you're paying noodles and taxes, which will be accept people very happy.
Yeah. It's California. It's a break percentage.
Um, so you and I connected in part because there was, um,
an Asian American political event. We're trying to rally folks in the community.
Um,
do you have a different perspective on what's going on politically as a result
of the fact that you had to essentially fight to stay in this country,
you become a citizen. Uh, and then now you are in my mind,
one of the most prominent Pakistani American figures, which,
and I'm, I can relate to aspects of this because you know,
there aren't that many like Asian American, um, uh, presidential candidates.
No, that, not that many. Let me see how many I can think of.
Yeah. There's an Andrew Yang. Um, so, uh,
I feel like you became a citizen just as our country started to really, um,
turn against each other or feel like it's getting torn apart. Um,
and I take it that you're with, so you know about me,
like I've endorsed Joe and Kamilah like, uh, you know,
I'm trying to get folks to just vote, vote, vote,
because I feel like the more people that vote the better off we're going to be.
Um, but I feel like you have a different perspective because you're like,
I kind of a recently minted American dude, it's like,
you had to to get it.
And then here we are at this political moment where it feels like there's a
ton at stake, uh, in November.
Yeah. And you know, I always feel like obviously, uh,
I relate to immigration issues, very intimately. And this,
the demonization of immigrants.
You remember when they were talking about the caravan from Mexico and stuff? I,
it never, first of all,
I find it obviously moral and immoral and unethical.
But on top of that, it's also extremely illogical because, you know,
you were born here. We had to like fight to come here.
We chose America as our home. We gave up our lives. You know,
we put everything on the line to choose,
to choose like better lives for ourselves and our families. I mean,
what's more American than that, right? The pursuit of life, what is it? Life,
Liberty, happiness, whatever it is. I don't remember from the citizenship.
The test test was too long ago, a long time ago.
That should be something that's commanded. I mean, these people are patriotic.
They chose America. They weren't just born here. So,
so I find that it just never makes sense to me that people are able to
demonize immigrants so easily. And yeah, obviously this election is very,
very important. You know, my parents moved here after I did.
My parents have been here now maybe, uh,
like 12 years or so. Um,
and they moved from Karachi and they,
they landed here and they love America. You know, they were like, Oh my God,
things are like much easier here. They felt really accepted. They just,
my mom was like seeing her that happy and that comfortable.
It just brought so much joy to me. And then in the last few years,
it's been very difficult for her. You know,
her relationship to America has changed and the way she looks,
the way she sees America has changed. Um, now when I talked to her,
uh, all she does is really talk about politics and how scared she is.
And she says, they don't want us here. I'm like, no, mom,
this is like, there's a certain percentage of people. This is not how it is.
Things can turn very quickly. And she was like,
she said something that really broke my heart. She was like, we already,
we already left Pakistan. Where, where do we go from here? Where will we go?
And we have to leave here.
Heartbreaking. You know,
she'd been here for 12 years and she's happy for the first 10 years.
And then the last two years, she was like, wait a minute. Like,
I'm not sure if this place actually wants people like me.
Yeah. It's been, it's been really, really, really dumb.
Thank you for listening in. I hope you enjoyed this conversation. If you did,
please do subscribe to yang,
speaks and click on notifications so we can let you know every time we have a
new episode.